foreign
[Music]
how are you
better than I deserve what's up
um okay so I am kind of on baby step
number one I've been also well I I
thought I was on two but it turns out
I'm back on one so I had somebody put
away and my savings were were okay and
so I made a lump sum payment on my
student loans which was great but now
like after a couple things happened now
I'm kind of back at square one but I
just feel like every paycheck I'm
reaching more into my emergency fund
because it's like I'm always behind in
each paycheck I'm catching up from
something I miss the previous two weeks
and I just like I just can't uh I can't
get ahead
what's causing you to be in the hole
right now which expenses is it
my student loan payment
like killer so what's your income
um it kind of It kind of varies so I'm
on salary for the first time in my life
too which is very different for me
um but uh yeah so like salary is three
thousand dollars a month and then I
might make another
um like a thousand dollars with just
like the extra work that I've been doing
um but that varies again so it just
depends on on kind of what's available
and what's your minimum payments and all
of your debts
um our minimum payment for my student
loans is 650 a month and then I have a
200 car insurance payment my rent is
eight hundred dollars
um and then I'm trying to think I have
like kind of insurance that's only like
50 bucks a month but it like the small
things are really adding up to
um
well the student loans alone
I'm 25 I just turned 25. okay
and um good all right well here's the
thing
um it sounds like hey you just started
this process
and B it sounds like when you write down
your budget that it's more like a wish
or a suggestion
well yeah yeah like yeah so what I did
is I took I I went through all my
statements from the last like three or
four months and I went through
everything that I I can't change right
now like my student loan payments my gas
like that kind of stuff and I wrote that
all down as mandatory payment so then
everything else I broke up into are they
needs or they wants and so like even
when I do that on paper it's like I only
have like two to three hundred dollars
in between each paycheck and then
something comes up if that makes sense
because I know it takes time yeah you're
doing the budget wrong
okay okay because you shouldn't have any
money left on your budget you should
have it all every dollar should have a
name before the month begins so I want
you to pan back and say I got three
thousand dollars and if you don't have
three thousand dollars you need to get
three thousand dollars in other words if
that thousand dollar gig doesn't kick in
then you got to work an extra job make
sure you at least have three thousand
dollars all right now then I want you to
write down your mandatories you got the
800 you got the 200 you got the
different mandatories like you said that
are in there I want you to give all of
those dollars a name on that budget and
decide which paycheck each one's coming
out of
yeah before the month begins I want you
to completely plan out how you're going
to pay your bills
and that includes if you have money that
is a want that's left over then you're
going to plug it in as a want
if you have money that's in need a
mandatory you're going to plug it in as
that but if you have three thousand
dollars come in and you have planned to
spend three thousand dollars exactly and
you spend it exactly as you had planned
you're not going to have a crisis agreed
yeah
but what's happening is is that
um some friend calls and goes let's go
out for drinks
right yeah that's exactly and I just see
leftover money and think it's spendable
income yeah because it's left over and
if instead if you said I have this much
allocated for social
for happy hour you know I got 50 bucks
out okay for happy hour and you did that
last week then the friend calls you got
to say no but you don't have anything
that gives you a no button all you've
got yesterday
and your yes buttons are blowing up the
whole thing
but I feel like I'm saying no to
everything like I see it
you're not you're
not you're not you're just whining
you're just whining that's probably Fair
yeah you're not saying no to enough
that's why you're in crisis right are
you working extra on top of your
full-time job
yeah like I work like like 10 to 12 hour
days depending on the day okay but for
the same salary I'm saying do you have
extra jobs
yeah yeah so so my salary looks so I
like um I like teach group fitness
classes on top of my salary job and so
many classes as I can what's up to 55 an
hour oh that's good it just depends on
how many people show up and if it takes
time to for people to come to your
classes more and I have been getting
getting more so so you get 55 an hour
yeah if the class is full right now I'm
averaging 45. okay
you're not making that at your day job
no that's like I don't know if I should
quit no no no no you need the money
right now we don't need to quit anything
we need to do more but you know it
sounds to me like I you know what I
would do is try to do 40 hours worth of
Fitness work
right you'll be tired but you'll be fit
yeah and you won't have been going out
drinking you would have been getting fit
and making 45 dollars an hour and you
would have cleaned up this mess
right what's your total debt
uh sixty thousand dollars and student
loans purely I don't have any credit
cards and I don't have a car payments or
anything so here's the thing okay we're
going to ship you a copy of the book The
Total Money Makeover and show you
exactly how to do this
what I have figured out is the matter I
get about my situation the more extreme
I get about fixing my situation
and you're just beginning to get angry
but I just want to turn your anger up a
little bit that's kind of why I was
poking at you a little bit I want to get
you mad even if you're mad at me that's
okay
because I'll just be your coach I'll be
your friend that loves you enough to
take the blows okay so I want you to go
win girl and you you're smart we're
talking to you for a few minutes you're
not done doing any problem but your your
issue is focus and this extreme Focus
that comes from an extreme sacrifice
that comes from a healthy level of anger
is is really what the uh recipe is it is
a bit like Fitness stuff
um you know you tell people to do stuff
there's ones that kind of care and kind
of don't care but the ones that have to
lose weight or the doctor says they're
going to die they figure out a way to
lose the weight the ones that go you
know my my pants are just tight you know
they don't lose weight that's not enough
vanity is not enough to get you into the
bigger why you got to get fired up about
whatever it is whatever Behavior you're
doing that changes everything and
um you're getting there but you're just
starting this journey I've got real hope
for you I think a month from now you're
gonna be a beast oh yeah I remember when
I was getting out of debt day when I
started here and I was doing Uber I had
the Nielsen people meter to make another
20 bucks a month I was eating Lean
Cuisines waiting for them to go five for
ten on sale ooh that's gross but it was
worth it and I will never eat a Lean
Cuisine again amen amen you gotta have
something you'd never eat again because
you had to eat it when you're broke
broke people food find that food you
know ramen noodles tuna fish for me I
hate tuna fish
yeah hang on we'll send you a copy of
that book kiddo you call us anytime we
can help